it is now being officially reported that
the doj has hit trump allies with 40
subpoenas
effectively confirming what steve bannon
said the other day now bannon said that
35
trump allies senior trump officials or
or associates were hit by the feds now
we're getting the official reporting
from the new york times 40 subpoenas so
maybe that's 40 people maybe it's 35
people harmeet delano a lawyer also
confirmed that number and uh ben went on
to say that the fbi is acting like the
gestapo and uh it's getting crazy at the
same time donald trump showed up in dc
in golf shoes in a polo and the internet
erupted with conspiracy theories about
his secret meeting what was he doing
well at first they thought he was being
arrested or indicted or answering
questions to the doj or something like
that some speculated it was a health
crisis but they were like why would he
show up in golf clothes he must have
been forced to come it's going to be his
arrest
and it's like maybe he's going golfing
and then he goes to a golf course now
the conspiracy theory is that
he's at a golf course with no golf clubs
and a bunch of top trump allies and so
they're saying that he met an open field
so they could talk in private without
being bugged or something okay maybe you
know somebody's been leaking stuff out
of trump world so
i guess we'll see how that plays out and
then another funny story that democrat
out of vegas who was arrested and
charged with murder of a journalist no
less who is denied bail
will stay in office
and keep getting paid
okay
sure before we get started my friends
head over to timcast.com become a member
if you'd like to support our work as a
member you'll get access to exclusive
segments well exclusive shows really you
can check the cass castle vlog and
tonight at 11 pm we're gonna have an
uncensored not so family-friendly show
we put that up at tencast.com so sign in
and support our work help keep this big
machine churning if you really do like
it smash the like button subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends joining us to talk about this
and their film
are some of the guys behind the
documentary documentary series now i
suppose uncle and the second word in the
name is tom that one was for the youtube
algorithm so i don't know whoever wants
i don't want to introduce yourself there
you go
thanks for having us tim we're like i'm
not going to make one of you go first
yeah my name is justin malone i'm the
director editor of uncle tom and uncle
tom two
uncle second word time uncle
tom
there you go
um yeah so we're really excited to be
here uh spend some time with you guys
talk about our film and uh absolutely
have some fun
right on we got shadow
i'm chad o jackson i am a uh texas
business owner
i am featured in the 2020 uncle
tom
[Laughter]
maybe that will get past the algorithm
we need to figure out the delay time
right yeah i mean i gotta bounce with
everybody i really don't think youtube
cares that much i think it's funny yeah
and i'm also a co-writer uh co-producer
co-editor
of the 2020
or 2022 version which just came out last
month um uncle
second word tom two
which is third word two yeah there you
go third word two so right on guys
thanks for joining us thank you and then
some guy is sleeping in my parking lot
again i don't think the paws helps the
algorithm but anyway
welcome back beautiful and amazing human
beings my name is okadelski if we are
change.org it is good to be back tim as
you know i rushed back here because i
just really wanted to come before the
october surprise there's so many
psyopses there's so much trauma-based
mind control we are here to call it out
on the front lines it's going to be a
crazy end of the year i'm here for it so
really happy to be back and uh if you
like the depiction of this very plump
juicy fbi agent represented on my
t-shirt that is sitting on labor lady
lady liberty as she is screaming in pain
and horror you could get it on the best
political shorts.com good to be back
thank you so much for having me i think
that he has the communist fists on his
mask and it's a rainbow damn right i
love it i am also here in the corner
already turning the volume down for luke
what we are change welcome back luke uh
interesting t-shirt i'm looking forward
to seeing what else you have to offer us
while you're here let's get into it
tonight here's the first story we have
in the new york times justice department
issues 40 subpoenas in a week expanding
its january 6 inquiry it also sees the
phones of two top trump advisors a sign
of an escalating investigation two
months before the midterm elections now
this
this is like october surprise territory
they say we're not supposed to do
anything 60 days before an election okay
well they just did and they're go and
they're likely going to keep doing it i
think it's possible trump gets indicted
i don't know for sure
they say the seizure of the phones
coupled with a widening effort to obtain
information from those around mr trump
after the 2020 election represents some
of the most aggressive steps the
department has taken thus far in its
criminal investigation into the actions
that led to the january 6 assault on the
capital by a trope a pro-trump mob
that's interesting they said assault not
insurrection
the extent of the investigation has come
into focus in recent days even though it
has often often been overshadowed by the
government's
legal clash of mr trump and his lawyers
over a separate inquiry blah blah blah
okay now they're just kind of just you
know fluffing words up in this article
we get it the big news is that they went
after trump they went after trump
supporters and trump allies and people
working with trump so i guess uh
i don't know is banana republic is this
we're gonna have a free and fair
election this november or is the fbi
interfering right now with the
republican party this is a very
dangerous escalation which is being met
with the biden administration laying
down the groundwork for really not just
tough talk but tough actions we've seen
hillary clinton just today compare trump
supporters to al qaeda we saw kamala
harris on 9 11 at ground zero describe
how threats against democracies should
be treated like terrorists we saw biden
on 911 also specifically say how terror
victims should stand up for democracy
they're laying the groundwork for
something very serious i think they're
acting like a scared animal that's being
backed in a corner because everyone's
telling people to vote republican
whether it's aaron rodgers whether it's
joe rogan they're coming out and saying
hey vote republican i think they see the
republicans as a threat and i think when
you have an animal that that's in a
corner it could do anything at any
moment and i think the animal's afraid
and it could bite and i think there's
going to be some larger consequences
moving ahead uh as as
you know their grip of power is slowly
unleashing and and you know becoming
loose now you're 100 right and you know
to your question i i think it's the the
latter of the three
uh
and the interesting thing about this is
that all this could have been avoided
um there were speculations of
irregularities in the
you know 2020
election
and if
the
[Music]
if the appropriate people would have
taken those allegations seriously or
those
those concerns seriously and looked into
it
in a
in a responsible way then that would
have
evaded a lot of what ended up happening
i agree so yeah uh they didn't though a
lot of the lawsuits were thrown out on
standing not the merits and my attitude
was
give give them what they want right and
because i i'm like the end result is
likely going to be the same
there was a lot of crazy i mean it's
crazy to me that you had people coming
out talking about venezuelan servers and
gun fights in germany and satellites
stealing data and i'm like okay guys
come on like say oh okay let's hear what
you have to say and let people hear that
because that's going to get dismissed
immediately instead we just got
procedural grounds which i don't know i
got to be honest maybe what they really
wanted was
discontent
you know uh if you take a look at
january 6 there were cops opening the
door for people so maybe they were
thinking like we could quash this but
maybe we want them all riled up so they
act a fool and then we can make them
look bad well they're also invested into
this and i think this is more of a
phishing operation than an actual
investigation because usually when you
have you know the fbi going after
somebody there usually is a crime but
but to go after the supporters we don't
know exactly who these individuals are
but this is all related to january 6th
okay how far away from that date are we
specifically and and and what do they
have they might not have anything but
with these subpoenas they might be
investigating trying to find something
because i think they're desperate for
something to blame the republicans on it
and i'm not a trump supporter and to me
what's happening is extreme extremely
scary and it and it's really bringing us
to a very desperate situation in this
next upcoming election that is dangerous
for everyone well that's how you know
it's a cult because they'll call you
luke a trump supporter yeah even when
you're like i don't like the guy but
this is crazy they'll be like you like
trump i i called him out during his
presidency i thought i think anyone
anyone in power should be held
accountable but but
but again what's happening here to trump
is making everyone in the middle see the
situation and see this doesn't really
add up this doesn't really make sense it
really is an overreach of power and
abuse of power that we see
in a lot of developing countries but
happening here it's it's very very
dangerous especially with our current
cultural climate yeah absolutely certain
a very
uh
negative precedence for the future of
american politics and i would hate to
see people you know on the republican
side doing the same thing for their
democratic uh adversaries and so i i'm
just you know i'm very concerned about
what kind of precedence that's for sure
i think people are losing confidence
especially in the fbi
steve bannon comes out on his show it's
a massive show he's talking with charlie
kirk on another massive show and he says
that they're basically it's a it's a
weaponization it's a political it's it's
biden's gestapo we had that one poll
that showed i think what was it like a
majority of people thought that uh i
think might have been rasmussen majority
of people thought that there was a there
was an element of the fbi that were
acting like joe biden's personal gestapo
i think it was james lindsay was it was
it james who said he's on he was on a
plane with somebody that was james yeah
he's on a plane with some women and she
was like you know i don't like trump but
the fbi going to his house like that's
too much for me i wonder sometimes
it's hard to know exactly how that's
going to play out is this going to
demonize trump and trump supporters and
attempt for the dem by the democrats to
say haha maga evil
because it seems like that was their
play they they you know the democrats
were propping up republican candidates
propping up their messages
and the and the media reported as well
they want the trump-supported candidates
the trump endorsed candidates to win
so that they can win in the general so
get them in the primary and this seems
to be in line with that they prop up the
messaging of trump supporters once trump
supporters win 92 endorsement success
from trump they then do things like this
biden comes out and says maga is evil
blah blah blah or extremist and then it
scares the public or maybe it'll have
the inverse effects like how do you how
do you know maybe people will see this
and they'll be like yo they've gone too
far and then end up voting the other
direction
i think historically america has always
bounced out of these situations
whenever we go too far down the
left rabbit hole
i think americans tend to shake
themselves out of it and i think that's
why to your point they're running scared
because
america has such a unique history
uh we are individuals by nature
um
so i think once you once you go too far
once you put americans you know in a
corner they tend to like wake up i mean
trump winning the 2016 election proved
that
uh say what you want about the the the
2020 election but the fact that trump
won the election and the fact that they
put so much effort into demonizing him
in a full-on assault from our media
in in 2016
they they launched this whole insane
theory about trump uh not actually
having one legitimately that the
russians were colluding and a whole
bunch of their nonsense and they were
allowed to do it yeah across the board
across the media the corporate press and
all the institutions were supporting it
they launched fbi investigations well i
think what trump has done for the
country is you know you know like him or
hate him you know he's he's turned the
light on and he's and he's shown us you
know he's forced the hand of our media
in a way that no president in our
lifetime ever has
and you see a lot of people waking up
and so
again i think you know countries that
have fallen to this ideology in the past
um they didn't have our history they
didn't have our spirit
and so in our guns and our guns yeah i
mean to your i mean so i mean you know
you know in our office space you know
we're kind of divided like there's
there's some people that are more
pessimistic and some people that are
more optimistic i'm more on the
optimistic side because i think
americans
tend to uh pull out of these situations
we saw it in the 60s we saw it in 68
when when they went too far americans
tend to wake up americans tend to go
back to being americans and now we're
seeing it we're seeing it with our
economy uh we're seeing it with you know
people
i think the brilliance of the media is
not only that deception but they they're
good at convincing people that most
people think the way that they're
telling you they think
and so there's a lot more people that
are logical than we know
but because we can only have so many
interactions with people in the
day-to-day so i'm optimistic about
america
and they're gonna push and push and push
because of their desire for power and
eventually it might turn nasty but
americans are generationally free and we
have an independent spirit that no other
country in the history of the world has
ever seen i remember two years ago being
on this show and documenting how biden
and the corporate media got into power
because essentially their their major
campaign slogan was we're not donald
trump he got into office and he kept
saying we're not donald trump donald
trump's about donald trump's bet and
they kept obsessing about donald trump
and we were watching his administration
we're like okay what are you going to do
what policies are you going to put
forward the democrats don't have
anything except for donald trump as a
way to galvanize the general public and
they don't have anything to show for
their records within the last few years
what they have is devastation they've
wrecked this economy they pushed up
world economic forum great reset
policies that have devastated the middle
class that have made people more poor
they have no record to stand on other
than the destruction of our society and
i think this is why in part we have this
obsession with trump trump trump trump
because they don't have anything else to
stand behind but also at the same time i
do believe that this is a part of a
larger divide and conquer agenda to make
sure blue-collar americans fight each
other and this is the perfect kind of
pendulum swing point that we're at where
we have trump and we have biden this is
the perfect way to distract all of us
and have all of us fighting and not
looking at the true cause of our pain
this is why they're going after the maga
republicans why joe biden is like the
maggot or what we call it maggie
republicans because they know trump's
not going to be around forever they
can't use him as their as their weapon
so when trump you know either retires or
loses or whatever happens they need that
anger because it's the only thing that
brings the left together enough yeah if
trump bows out this is one of the
reasons why i lean a little bit in the
direction of desantis though i'm fairly
split between the two i'm starting to
lean a little bit more desantis these
days it goes back and forth but i think
the reason might be
trump as a powerful prominent figure
is is easily recognizable and easy to
use in media what
either for loving him or hating him
desantis
with all due respect is a more boring
character the people who know him
love him the people who know his
policies respect him but most people
don't care he's not a celebrity donald
trump was the on the apprentice donald
trump is the tv reality guy so everyone
was like oh yeah we know donald trump
and then they get back here's why he's
bad here's why he's good and everybody
just loves to stare at the man i think
everyone to say his wins
they will try the maga republican thing
but it's not going to work yeah so
what's likely going to happen is
right now you have leftists and you have
democrats for some reason united it
makes no sense it's like the the people
who posing the one percent teaming up
with the one percent don't ask me why
well the i guess you could the answer is
they hate donald trump you get trump
under the equation and they're going to
scream maga republicans and people are
going to be like who's that
who are we mad at now i don't know what
you're talking about are we mad at some
maybe that works in local elections it's
not going to work nationally and then
what happens is the left the democrats
this democratic socialists they they all
break up into different factions once
again fighting each other like occupy
wall street was angry with democrats and
then you're going to get the maga
coalition which is a massive group of
conservatives libertarians post liberals
politically homeless individuals and
then i think you see
some kind of like maga sweep that's if
and when they lose the ability to rally
people around hating trump yeah
like so with this uh last speech that
biden gave like it was pretty pathetic
that here you have a president who's two
years in office and he's making his
latest speech about what trump and
magger republicans
he doesn't have a record to stand on in
terms of the positives that he has been
able to
uh put forth in these past two years and
so he makes it about you know building
an enemy and basically
doubling all focuses on that enemy and
getting people to hate that enemy and
saying things like if we come together
they can we can march forward to a
better future it's it's very pathetic
but you know for me you know to your
point about about desantis uh from a
spectator's point of view the santas
have proven to be
effective in terms of like uh
staring down and and being effective
against a lot of the kind of woke
policies that are coming uh down the
tubes and so for a lot of people i feel
like they will be attracted to a
desantis type person
come 2024
based on his effectiveness in a place
like florida and his backbone yeah not
only the effectiveness but also the
prospects of potential peace and not
craziness from the other side that of
course is extremely hyperbolic extremely
sensationalistic and they know if
trump's going to go in there he's going
to be looking for redemption that's the
kind of ideas that's the type of
thinking that a lot of people have and i
would see the the party establishment
galvanize more people against that than
potentially a desantis who again also
interesting figure i go back and forth
on him as well i think any person in
politics should be criticized but you
made that point that i was trying to
make you made it a lot more eloquently
than i did they have nothing to stand on
except for the destruction of the
american working class and i think at
the end of the day both political
parties have caused these policies that
destroyed
the blue-collar workers in this country
that have destroyed the way of life in
this country that have destroyed civil
liberties and any kind of economic
prosperity that we had before and right
now i think we're in limbo of a lot of
chaos that that is hitting people all at
once and i think we're we're even at a
point where people don't know how to
even respond to all of this all at once
let's jump to this story we got from
newsweek donald trump leads group around
the golf course during mysterious dc
visits so at first
there was this big conspiracy trump
shows up in dc he's wearing golf shoes
in a polo and they're like whoa whoa
whoa why is he not dressed up clearly
the only reason is that he's facing a
rest he was golfing they grabbed him
made him go someone then says these
leftist conspiracy theorists no no maybe
he's going to the hospital
maybe it was an abrupt trip he's got to
go to walter reed or something
some people were like dude maybe he's
going golfing
or i think the simple thing was like
sometimes people wear comfortable
clothing like he's wearing golf shoes
i don't know where sometimes he wears
suits sometimes you don't
so everybody was speculating nobody knew
and now we get the latest theory
here's a one of the this is a tweet with
107 retweets don the con man is in dc
quote golfing with kevin mccarthy devin
nunes eric trump sean hannity no golf
clubs how many guys does it take to help
trump find his balls ha ha so i don't
know what they're doing but there is
this photo that's going around i don't
know if those names are correct it said
kevin mccarthy but i don't know if he's
actually there what's the guy in red
holding that looks like a golf club it's
not a golf club i don't know what it is
but uh there are pictures of them on the
golf course in golf carts without golf
clubs
so the theory now is that these are
trump allies meeting in big open fields
with no devices away from recordings to
have a conversation i guess
and now the theories are once again uh
donald trump's gonna get arrested so let
me just say without further ado the
walls are
closing in closing in yes
the the the end is nigh the end is near
um the beginning of the end for donald
trump what else what what are the other
ones
bombshell report
republicans pounce republicans no i
don't know about that one but bombshell
the walls are closing in the end is near
for trump this is the beginning of the
end
great this again part of me kind of
feels like they're not going to arrest
trump and they're doing all of this in
very high profile ways like the fbi
raids to put on a show to make people
think it will happen because the best
they can do
but at the same time you know i don't
know man what do you guys think you
think trump's having secret meetings to
discuss his strategy to avoid arrest or
plot a coup or what's he doing well if
if trump's uh arrested that's only going
to help people like desantis so i think
that also plays into the sphere of
what's happening here especially when it
comes to a lot of these central
controllers but also there's what 40 uh
indictments i i think he probably wrote
subpoenas like sorry 40 subpoenas he
probably bought brought the boys around
to be like hey there's 40 subpoenas
what do we do
i've heard some rumors yeah we don't
know what happened but but uh we can
only speculate from here i've heard some
rumors from
people close
close to trump's inner circle that their
conversations strategy about you know
whether or not they take this seriously
i want to be light on how i phrase it
because i don't want to play those
stupid games but uh you know i wouldn't
come out with an article and be like
definitively state this the media likes
to be like sources close to trump circle
say x and it's like what does that
really mean so i'm just saying it's a
rumor that trump's you know having
conversations like doing to take this
seriously or not we're going to move
forward and uh whatever that ends up
becoming i don't know but i think luke
is right he called the boys and said
guys 40 subpoenas we better have a
meeting about this
well i don't think it's illegal to to me
i mean the thing what the media is doing
is they're making everything that trump
does as if he's already a criminal as if
he's already been indicted as if he's
already been
you know proven guilty and so thing you
know like an ex-president playing golf
with his friends is not news but
whenever you you know write the headline
in such a way
you know people that you know
don't study this stuff you know like
like we do like they're they might be
susceptible to to
uh thinking that trump is doing
something so it's really a non-story but
if you put the right headline on it then
a lot of people might and it's all it's
also about just freezing trump like
we've been talking about like freeze
trump
keep people angry about trump keep
people thinking about trump trump's your
enemy trump's you know trump's going to
destroy our democracy trump trump trump
trump
um and unless you you know are educating
yourself on how these you know these
deceptive tactics work then you might
fall for it but to me like everything
that we just saw is a non-story yeah
yeah like trump trump hangs out at golf
course breaking news it's like trump's
an ex-president like since when does an
ex-president not play golf with his
friends and since no golf clubs though
since when do a bunch of republicans not
talk i mean is it they're republicans
they're supposed to be strategizing we
gotta be democrats right i mean that's
the whole point you don't know who it is
yeah this person's claiming it's known
as they know who it is but they're using
a shot that's making you think they
don't know who it is so it seems more
conspiratorial and more uh well i'm
saying this person on twitter doesn't
know who it is oh okay they're listing a
bunch of random names but you can't
actually see that well okay so you use
the word pounce earlier republicans
pounce because this is the one this is
the uh the verbiage that the left loves
to use and
you know meanwhile this is a prime
example of of the left pouncing you know
i mean uh it's interesting how they're
constantly
accusing conservatives of being
conspiracy theorists and you know
they're making everything a thing but
you know
they they are tweeting about how oh
they're having a meeting with there's
you know there's no golf clubs you know
i mean it's like it's like they're
trying to make something out of nothing
you know i mean so it's like it's very
interesting just the kind of hypocrisy
that's going on here well that's why i
wonder why should we take any of it
seriously you know i got like a
corporate press emailing me this is
really funny the washington post emailed
me today like right before the show and
they were like we have a list of people
who said
that uh biden did not win the election
fairly and your name is included on this
list and i just started laughing when i
saw that i'm like okay so i get the
trump the diehard trumper is calling me
a cuck because i said biden did win and
trump did lose and then i get the
corporate press claiming that i said the
opposite this is just absolutely amazing
why should i take any any of the the
corporate press seriously they're just
gonna lie they're gonna make things up i
can come on the show over and over again
and say that biden won because uh people
hated trump and trump supporters you
know they can't believe it they couldn't
believe it and of course there was the
the shadow campaign stuff in time
magazine i'm not downplaying any of that
stuff but the media is going to say that
whatever they want no matter what you do
and they're going to find a way to
justify it they're going to put out
stories like this for all we know you
know what i love i'm like the me these
people come out and they're like it's a
conspiracy trump's meeting no golf clubs
what's he talking about he's plotting
another coup and i'm like donald trump
sitting here with all his friends he's
like thank you for joining me gentlemen
this is an excellent investment property
it's going to be a time share golf
course trust me and that's like for all
we know he's meeting to sell property
it's like you got a bunch of friends
together we're going to go look at a
building you're interviewing there's a
million and one reasons when people were
claiming he was going to the hospital
because he was dying they were like well
if he was dying someone would be would
be helping him and he's not he's not
being helped therefore it means it's
probably not a medical emergency and so
he's probably being indicted and i'm
like if he broke his wrist he would be
walking just fine there's a million in
one reasons you could make up as to why
trump went to dc yeah they just make
stuff up they go nuts with it if if only
there was this much media attention and
scrutiny on the world economic forum the
bilderberg group jeffrey epstein the
world would be a better place but no
we're still obsessing about donald trump
the corporate media's gift that keeps
giving they're obsessing about him i'm
sick of even just hearing about this
nonsense who cares he met and he talked
to people people do that all the time
you should see what what
corporations do with the politicians
that they buy and all the private
conversations that they have selling you
down the river but of course we don't
have that kind of media attention we
don't have that kind of scrutiny and
this is why in part we're dealing with
so many problems in our everyday lives
because of this nonsense that again is
just politics astray that is just
screwing people over no but you make it
actually an excellent point though uh
why are they not putting this kind of
scrutiny on the world economic forum on
themselves you know on themselves
because the thing is the fact of the
matter is that i know trump apologists
you know as as you put it um but it
makes you wonder are they in on the
agenda that
organizations like the world economic
forum are putting out probably and they
see trump and others like him as a
threat to their agenda and so of course
they're going to
demonize and try to in a sense uh
put this kind of focus and freeze
individuals who they see as a threat and
trump is just one of them i just want to
point something out too like this
picture that we have showing trump and a
bunch of people like sitting around like
standing around this empty golf course
i'm just imagining like what if trump is
speaking to them and he's like where are
the golf clubs at the people they were
the caddies were supposed to bring them
and now we're standing here i'm so sorry
gentlemen and someone's like they don't
have golf clubs and it's like
how common is it
normal
for someone to be like it's going to be
15 minutes so the caddies get here i
guess they got held up instead they go
with this crazy conspiracy trump's
having secret meetings and plots and
whatever
it's like the most likely scenario is
they're waiting for golf well that's
what's going to backfire on them and it
always has historically i mean for them
to come after you right i mean you make
a point to be open-minded to do your
research but for them to come after you
it's like what that's not it's not
helping them right and it's not helping
you know your audience
go their way so i think that they over
play their hand yeah they they tweet
things out like this
i mean there's a number of reasons why
they don't have golf clubs like who
cares like he's an ex-president he's
literally an ex-president he's allowed
to play golf and talk to his friends or
his constituents there's no crime well
here i think i think it might have been
cernovich who said i'm not sure that no
no who said this someone said this to us
that this is the true crime podcast for
you know wine moms or like wine ants and
it's like the latest season of the trump
scandal like they actually have true
crime podcasts that sit there like women
talk about trump and what he's doing so
they need this they need it they need it
all her she wrote yeah now mueller's
gone and it still exists what exists
yeah trump said cnn would kind of fail
after he was gone right i mean oh yeah
they're still talking like trump's
literally just hanging on mar-a-lago and
they're that's all they can talk about
so it's you know i i agree with luke i'm
just kind of exhausted like let's move
on you know you guys have the white
house you guys you have everything you
want why are you still hung up and you
know again it's like they're they're
doing more damage you know for their
cause than than good that's why i wonder
if this shift to desantis would would
work out better because
then like i was saying before trump is
this this big powerful figure and he can
rally the left or the right desantis has
the right but the left doesn't care he's
not a celebrity they've tried smearing
him going after him but i'll tell you
man you you have you seen those videos
that flecos puts out we talked about
them before the show for those that are
listening where it's like the dude goes
out of time square and asks people
questions and they're really dumb and
it's really it's really terrifying and
then you see those videos and you're
like now i understand bill gates anyway
you know easy
i don't understand bill gates
after watching those videos
uh if you go to those people and you say
what do you think about donald trump
what do you think those people are going
to say uh racist bigot you know if you
go to those people and say what do you
think about rhonda sanders what are they
going to say what does that mean who's
that like who's that yeah
exactly
so if you start seeing a 2024 desantis
run and trump is out of the picture
they're going to try and be like
desantis is evil and people are like
who's that yeah you do trump and they're
like oh yeah trump f trump
you know i've been seeing videos though
where they're going into the inner
cities and they're going you know a lot
of younger people um they
miss trump they liked trump and
you know the thing is is that you know
trump was
part of all of our lives growing up
right i mean he's at home alone right
he's everywhere and
so i think that really backfired which
is probably why he won
so again i think they've overplayed
their hand um and and americans i have
faith that americans are not as dumb as
you would think that americans are if
you if you're just following what the
news and what social media is telling us
yeah and that's an interesting point
justin because um trump from 2016 to
2022 or to 2020 he jumped four percent
in terms of getting the so-called black
vote
you know so he was gaining momentum in
terms of black people who are voting for
him and so
you know they obviously understand that
to the extent that hispanics and
black people are voting for
trump a so-called republican president
this is a very real threat and so you
want to double down you want to
mobilize all of your radio personalities
i mean if you listen to
any black you know urban radio program
uh on a morning radio show they're
constantly demonizing trump even though
he's not in office and so they're
constantly mobilizing you know a lot of
these urban and hispanic posts las vegas
official accused of killing reporter
will remain in office what and get paid
what
okay so this is a democrat
and he's there wearing some kind of what
is that a clean suit or something
biomass it's a smock
so uh this guy has been arrested
innocent until proven guilty
charged with the murder he's arrested on
the on murder suspicion of a journalist
who was who was covering running hit
pieces
and so this guy
they find his dna at the scene that
that's that's what happened right lydia
i want to make sure yeah
he's been arrested
and he's still
in office he's still getting paid he's
wearing a dexter suit when this reporter
runs into him what is going on here so
uh how many people do you know could
keep their jobs when they go to jail for
murder when they're arrested and charged
awaiting trial well well tim we also
have to understand that you know
politicians murder people all the time
and they get away with that
do you understand what happens behind
did you see the wars that they started
do you see the drone bombs that they
sent over i mean if this guy's going to
go to jail barack obama right now turn
yourself in for the assassination of
and his son and a 16 year old american
citizen that was executed by you
personally when you signed off on the
order to kill an american 16 year old
child
and he got to stay in office he got to
stay in office he got a government
paycheck so you know why should this get
kicked out of office government obama
killed an american kid
literally killed a 16 year old american
citizen abdulrahman i love saying that
as often as possible and this is not the
first time i mean i mean presidents have
started conflicts have started wars have
started even
you know done
actions that have led to the end of many
people's lives i just i would love to
see obama turning himself in to the las
vegas police and he'd be like well
if he's gone i guess so much yep and it
was on and they just lock him up and
throw him in a cell and it was a number
of american citizens it wasn't just one
yeah it was it was around seven two to
eight the number is still unknown
because there there was a lot of covert
ops surrounding a lot of these actions
but but essentially barack obama
literally signed off on a lot of these
executions that without a judge without
a trial without a jury executed american
citizens and killed them and that's the
power that he gave donald trump donald
trump uh made sure that the the
accounting and records of it wasn't
public and he gave the power to the
pentagon to make these decisions and he
made sure that the records weren't
public trump had too much faith in the
military he really revered these guys
and boy did that screw him over in a lot
of ways especially with those who lied
to him about syria but um
was it was a collateral murder was that
bush that was bush right i believe that
was bush and uh chelsea manning uh that
released that footage was that true the
footage i'm wondering i think i think it
might have been under bush i'm not sure
it might have been under obama because i
think that was released in like 2010
wasn't it but it happened under i mean
it was old video footage what happened
under bush right right the reason i
bring that up is i thought it was bush
because it just shows you how these
powers get passed down yeah that obama
is promising you all the bells and
whistles and then you know he gets in he
kills people all the same
so uh you know what throwing it back to
this story about this guy in vegas
um
luke is right like are we now going to
change our policies i'm surprised this
guy actually got charged i suppose
i i don't know honestly what's what's
the difference really barack obama
signed off on a drone strike on a
civilian restaurant in yemen a country
we were not at war with and he blew up a
16 year old american citizen who had
committed no crimes
so i just i gotta wonder like that to me
is actually worse for a few reasons
first of all he killed a child
second of all he killed he blew up a
civilian restaurant
firing missiles into countries around
war with i'm like man it just compounds
and so much worse
and then it's also just like you know i
i understand it's not as important but
the tens of millions of dollars it cost
to do that now you're stealing our money
too and this guy
this guy gets gets arrested the first
thing thinking about this story because
this was a very interesting story i
actually tweeted about this journalist
passing away because he was an
investigative journalist he was also one
of the few journalists that was actually
correctly investigating the las vegas
shooting which a lot of people have
totally forgot about which we still
don't have an explanation
we still don't have an official
explanation to exactly what happened in
las vegas during that during this mass
shooting event that of course it has so
many people push for for gun control but
but more importantly i originally
thought maybe this was somehow connected
i i put this story out before the
politician was even connected to this
story but the politician who is accused
of killing him was also caught by this
journalist cheating on his wife this
journalist ended his political career he
he was a high-profile democrat in las
vegas uh but but automatically hearing
the story i i thought about what bill
clinton said about uh house of cards if
you remember uh house of cards it was a
famous netflix show with kevin spacey
friends of all friends and of course
jeffrey epstein but but bill clinton
said that that house of cards was 99
percent real wow and in house of cards
the president assassinates a journalist
and kills them yeah kevin spacey kills
them so so that that automatically makes
me think of this there's a lot of things
happening behind the seat of power that
we still don't know about there's
there's this meme with an iceberg
showing the corruption that we know that
we know about and then the corruption
that we don't know about being this huge
piece of ice underneath the the water
and i think this is the current reality
that we're dealing with and if we would
know exactly what politicians the really
sinister the really bad ones we're up to
we would be shocked and i don't i think
it would change our whole political
landscape
i do think that trump was very different
from obama and from bush i certainly
think he made mistakes in who he trusted
but i i i actually think trump was an
outsider i think they didn't expect him
to win i think he did want to end the
wars i think he made a bunch of mistakes
i think he signed up on a bunch of bad
orders
but uh
you look at how hard they're going after
him he did sign the abraham accords he
did try and bring peace say north korea
and crossing into the dmz and things
like that
and i know a lot of people they don't
they don't think it's enough you know we
had dave smith on the show and mashed
ray last week and dave said he's still
doing bad and so that shouldn't be the
standard
so you know my view is just like
someone super chat to this i thought to
them instead they said this problem was
created over a hundred years you're not
going to solve it in 100 days you can't
expect one president to come in and then
just snap their fingers and just end all
of the really really bad awful stuff
but why does that have to be the
president because when i you know i see
stories like this like you know where
are all the men
yeah like where are the men in our
government
you know if you look at you know trump's
presidency if you're just taking that as
a litmus test it's like you had an
investigation the entire time he was
president so how is it
that his political enemies were able to
roll out mueller and the things that
were going on with russia the things
that were going on
how are they able to have a non-stop
investigation non-stop uh political
power
like where where are the men that are
constitutional where are the american
men to stand up to this type of stuff
not in politics yeah well it's just
interesting because i think what made
trump so appealing to everybody was that
he had balls yeah they that he got on tv
and he spoke his mind and talking about
you know his growth in the black
community is is like that resonated with
with with black america is that you had
a man a masculine man that got on tv
desantis has that as well yeah but all
the rappers loved donald trump
was all it was oh they were all the
music videos but it's like you know you
see this going on in las vegas it's like
is there no men is there no any like who
do we have in the senate right now
i mean you know you see these little
clips where it's like oh ted cruz rose
so and so or whatever but it's like no
like
you're not you're just you're just you
know you're you're you're playing a part
but you know our country is headed in a
downward spiral like where are the men
like yeah it's all theatrics i mean and
and washington dc
i mean there's no real
you know i'm not i'm not bought and paid
for by any politician so it's like i can
i can criticize them from a in an
objective way as a citizen of the united
states but it's like
all the politicians who
are on their so-called republican side
many of them are themselves corrupt at
least they demonstrate that i mean if
you look at what they're saying on
twitter and what their actual voting
record is many of them are no different
than the people on the other side of the
aisle and so to the extent that it comes
to uh standing up for true law and order
i mean the inscription on the supreme
court uh building is literally you know
equal justice under the law but they're
not applying that you know what i mean
and so there's no there's no real uh men
who who love this country are fighting
for the con the constitution of these
united states
in the senate or in the congress like
how is there a non-stop investigation on
trump like like is there no one on the
other side like do i mean are is no one
curious about some of the things on the
other side like where like when is
so you know
you got to go vote 57 days i think it is
that we're at 57 well vote yeah voting
voting will do so much but i mean
hopefully there will be some men that
will step up and but the thing is too
like people have to kind of get it out
of their head that the only election
that matters is the president of the
united states you know what i mean yeah
and that being said too some men but i
gotta i kind of feel like marjorie
taylor green is gonna be the one who
actually goes heavy into the
investigations and stuff there are some
women who uh
carrie yeah carrie lake yeah
yeah she uh she's been supportive of our
of our recent project so i mean you know
when i say men i'm just saying like men
that you know will stand up and like we
need some masculine energy some truth
you know
you have these little glimpses of it but
it's just it just might it's just
mind-blowing that you know non-stop
investigations committees you know
government spending on investigating i
mean you're using taxpayer dollars to
basically you know
uh
grab power for yourself and and and just
longing for the day and i think again
like that's what was so cool about trump
yeah you know love him or hate him it's
like it was just cool to see a man on tv
you know flip the bird at the media it
was just cool it was cool to you know
you know i remember those fake news yeah
i remember the press conferences like
how exciting i remember like kicking
like oh my goodness like i've never you
know it made me uncomfortable because i
hadn't even been conditioned to seeing
just weak
politicians but all all republican
politics is these days is basically
placating the left
uh to try to you know in a sense play it
safe so as to come to some kind of
common ground to keep some remnants of
things as they were that's basically
what republican politics is there is no
true kind of intentionality in terms of
preserving the republic of the united
states i mean you literally had the
president of the united states talking
about we need to preserve our democracy
and a lot of people have it in their
head that america is a democracy like
nobody challenged him in terms of the
mainstream media of like well no
actually we're not a democracy we're a
dem we're a constitutional republic like
nobody checked him on that and so it's a
problem but to but you know back to the
story about you know this politician who
will you know keep their position who
will continually get paid
this is in a sense like the same thing
that has been going on in terms of you
know politicians being above the law
they are an elitist class
and
you know we are expected as citizens to
kind of go along with it yeah you made a
good point just really quickly the
republicans now have almost the same
policies as the democrats nearly had 10
years ago and it's almost the same exact
thing that they're just vying for so i
especially agree with you i don't have a
lot of hope in voting but when it comes
to the men i think a lot of them have
been sterilized i think a lot of them
have been chemically castrated and i i
think there also is a bigger spiritual
and health fight happening that is
affecting our current landscape that i
think is also worth talking about
definitely yeah we are at spiritual we
are in spiritual war right now yeah
well what's going on with the dudes man
what do you what do you got what do you
got for us look what are you talking
about guys being sterilized or what well
you know there's there's a a huge
decline in uh sperm and reproductive
rates in iq in people's health there's a
huge increase of
people being fat there's a huge increase
of people not being healthy there's a
huge increase of respiratory diseases
and heart ailments that have been
dramatically increasing all over the
world and
you know it's fair to say that there has
been something happening that has
utterly devastated and destroyed the
modern men and whether you look at and
and family-friendly show here but but
specifically if you look at uh you know
reproductive organs they've been
shrinking um
i don't know if i could say the the
thing i want to say that
the the size between the two private
parts is also shrinking which which you
know what yes yes yes there's a lot of
things chemically happening right now a
lot of people are blaming plastics for
it as plastics have been found in
people's bloodstreams uh there's there's
a chemical warfare happening right now
that is affecting not just the human
body but the human mind and i think this
is why a lot of people have been going
crazy this is why i think there's more
homelessness
there's a bigger homelessness problem
out there than there was before which is
usually linked to a mental health crisis
i think right now we are going through
some kind of medical intervention that
that is not natural that is destroying
human life on this planet but but luke
a great man once said there are too many
people on this planet and uh that was
bill gates by the way and uh
don't you think he's right there are too
many people luke absolutely not i think
what elon musk has been talking about
the opposite problem occurring
especially in a few decades from now is
the real problem because it's actually
backed by science it's actually backed
by data that is not paid and bought for
by bill gates and it's highlighting a
huge crisis of civilization that's going
to be hitting our way especially in the
western world where people aren't making
children one because people can't
sometimes because people don't want to
because they've been brainwashed and
propagandized not to to me in my
personal opinion we are going through a
population reduction program a lot of
people don't know about it a lot of
people are not aware of it a lot of
people are just living their lives
trusting the authorities and they're
being chemically attacked and castrated
in a way that's going to stop them from
reproducing but yeah you think it's on
purpose absolutely i think there's two
motives here one is profit and incentive
and i think the other one is deliberate
and i think both are playing a part here
i think there's a few people that are
saying too many people in this world we
have to intervene we have to incentivize
the use of gmos we have to incentivize
the use of glassify we have to
incentivize the use of high fructose
corn syrup yeah real quick there are
people like bill gates who have publicly
stated they're too many people and we
have to take action absolutely now
beyond that you know there's there's
corporations that are incentivized to do
this because then big industries like
corn high fructose corn syrup and
glycophate are subsidized and of course
given to these corporations for very
cheap they of course give it out to the
general public and whether it's seed
oils high sugar or or just the the
chemicals that are banned in so many
other countries we give it to our
children the diet that our children are
given is absolutely horrendous it's
leaving to brain defects and it's
leaving towards a destroyed civilization
that of course won't be able to get up
from its feet because it's being
bombarded with poisons
i will add this though but like because
i agree 100 with what you're saying that
it is the
derivative of you know of a of of
something chemical but all would also
add that it's something derivative of
propaganda which is another word that
you use
um
we were talking before the show you use
the word choice you know i'm saying and
people think people choosing to eat bad
food right yeah exactly and so it's like
yeah it is something to do with choice
but that choice is part and parcel of
propaganda people are kind of reacting
to a certain pattern of stimuli that's
propagandized to them
by certain movements and certain things
that happen in a very pervasive and
innovative way you know second wave
feminism had a very uh negative effect
on how we move as a society you know i
mean going into the uh the
you know 21st century but there's two
other layers here that i think are
important to understand beyond just
propaganda one is that the food is
engineered to be chemically addictive so
when you have it it literally is
engineered to hit the pleasure centers
in your mind so you become addicted to
the sugar to the seed oils another
aspect to really understand here is that
it's also cheap and readily available
because it's subsidized by big
industries that have bought off
politicians that are going along with
this agenda and don't even know that
they're doing it yeah so we as people
are being led in the way that we that
they think we should go exactly you know
what i've been hearing a lot we've been
talking about this quite a bit over here
there are a bunch of people we know
who came from other countries or visited
other countries when they came to
america they gained weight yeah and they
all said the same thing like there's
like four or five people we have
anecdotally who've been like i eat the
exact same food and dinner the same
schedule i've always done but when i
came to america i started getting
gaining a bunch of weight
and then i'm like nah i gotta believe
maybe it's like
you think you're eating the same amount
like
you you would order rice and beans and
chicken then you come to america but the
plate's 10 times bigger maybe that's
what's happening
but they insist they're like that's not
true like i i will make the food myself
it's the same food and then we had a
couple people that moved back like
friends of ours and then the weight was
gone
so i'm wondering uh you know ian often
thinks it's the bromine
i don't know about brominated wheat
flour and stuff like that i don't know
about that i don't know what specific
chemical or whatever there is they're
putting stuff or something like that
you know but something something in our
food maybe i have no idea yeah there's
there's a number of things and it's it's
very hard to put your your kind of uh
finger on it to directly because we're
dealing with so much bureaucracy we're
dealing with so much corruption the fda
has approved so many different chemicals
that are banned that you cannot give to
people in many different countries but
here in the united states it's it's it's
okay but there's a rushed experimental
therapy we're gonna rush that through
that's perfectly safe and fine which is
absolutely crazy
and and bewildering and there's so many
different aspects and so many different
layers we could get into this but
there's a lot of other speakers and
scientists that i think we should maybe
try to have on the show
carnivore md he's also a really good
smart medical doctor that presents a lot
of this information and data a lot
better than i do but i've just been
awakened to this because you know after
i you know i quit smoking cigarettes you
know
i started to see really bad health
effects after uh giving up something
that you know was really bad for me i
was like what's really going on here and
it really put me down a path where i had
to research this and once you start
researching it you go down a rabbit hole
of holy cow
you go down the supermarket aisle and
you're loudly saying everything's here's
poison everything here is trying to kill
me or hurt me in some kind of way and i
make a point to say that loudly every
time i'm in the super bowl after you
hear me the fda is yet another you know
because you you mentioned the world you
know economic forum and so on and so
forth i would include in and amongst
that the fda so yes absolutely corrupted
organization hijacked by multinational
corporations that are not looking out
for your best interests that are
literally poisoning you with so many
chemicals that that yet again
illegal in so many places i saw yes i
saw uh i think yeah it was yesterday
yesterday we went down to the blue ridge
rock fest it was really really awesome
and uh driving around danville virginia
i saw an og pizza an original pizza hut
building it's like man i haven't seen it
was a long time jack pacob talks about
him yeah with the weird little red roof
yeah like that we were thinking about
going there we ultimately didn't go
there and i was reminded of that story
jack bosovic tells where he went to a
pizza hut bringing his kids because he
wanted them to have the experience he
had when he was a kid and then realizing
like what he had is gone and it was
disgusting and falling apart and now
pizza tends to be just like a strip mall
store with a delivery only
but i bring this up because you know
i remember we had uh we had papa john on
the show yeah and you know he likes to
say better ingredients better pizza papa
john's well he's not there anymore they
went woke and got broke and then kicked
him out but uh but he talks about how
you know they actually use better
ingredients so i looked it up sure
enough papa john's ingredients are like
basic the the cro the dough is like
flour water yeast and i was like wow and
the cheese is like skim milk and i'm
like okay and the sauce is like roma
tomatoes or whatever and sugar and then
i was like okay well that's really
impressive and then i look at pizza hut
i think pizza puts splenda in their
crust
they sweeten their crust with artificial
sweetener i could be wrong it's been a
while since i looked it up but that was
like
wow they really do want everything to be
sweeter and that's gross and then
dominoes i think i think they're not
they don't put like sweetener like that
in there but their ingredients is like a
whole bunch of weird chemicals that you
don't understand and it's crazy when you
realize
most of the big fast food chains except
for papa john's um it's it's weird
chemicals you're eating you can't you
can't produce i'm sorry you can't
pronounce yet you don't care that you're
eating it that to me is just weird yeah
and your body can't break it down so
your body is in a constant state of
inflammation that it can't deal with and
when it's inflamed it has a hard time
processing and working well and if your
guts not working well your brain is not
working well since your brain is
dependent on the chemicals produced in
your gut and i think a lot of this is
deliberate because if you could destroy
someone's health if you could destroy
someone's sanity and mental clarity you
could more easily enslave them because
if you have them in the pathetic fat
state you have them in a state where
they don't respect themselves and if you
don't respect yourself you're not going
to stand up for yourself and therefore
you're a lot easier to squash you're a
lot easier to control you're a lot
easier to manipulate and i think there's
a big agenda happening and this is my
own personal opinion that this is all
engineered and planted and created in a
way specifically to hurt us in
the worst possible way i think luke is
right about you know when people are fat
and slow and and tired they're easier to
control and that's why i gave luke a box
of cookies today you did two of them
i looked at that i'm like you're trying
to get me fat the second second since i
saw that we have these special cookies
that very fancy they are fudge dipped
birthday cake oreos
one's enough sprinkles and it says step
on snack and find out um they look
incredible they look they're amazingly
like it's like just they just look so
good i haven't had one it's a drug it
really is you eat one and then you know
you want to eat more but one cookie is
130 calories wow one cookie and there
and they're little oreos that's that's
that's food i guess man i gotta tell you
when the apocalypse happens survivalists
are gonna be like yes like this will
last months one a day one a day
you probably eat a couple of them and
then uh you just you've got to work with
energy yeah yeah quick energy i guess
until you until you crash and burn
yeah
let's go back to talking about the media
actually no no i don't talk about the
media let's talk about this this is a
crazy story
switzerland may jail people who turn
their heat above 66 degrees this winter
well good oh most people want to warm
their homes
they think they are this planet is warm
enough
citizens of switzerland who dare turn
their thermostats above a balmy 19
degrees celsius or 66 degrees fahrenheit
perfect temperature if you ask me over
the winter may instead find themselves
shipping shivering in a prison cell the
cause of natural gas in europe has
increased more than tenfold you guys see
that in italy they're doing things by
candlelight now at bars and restaurants
those who failed to comply with the
temperature mandates could receive
sanctions between thirty and three
thousand swiss francs the equivalent of
thirty one and three thousand ninety
dollars
federal department of finance spokesman
marcus
spjorn d sports bjorn lee am i
how do you pronounce that i hope it's
that's
foreign
told the outlet those found
intentionally violating the statute
would receive up to three years in
prison this is the next lockdown the
climate lockdown yeah
and they're going to implement it
through smart cities and smart meters
you know a couple years ago we saw
people screaming they're installing the
smart meters don't do it they're going
to control everything and people thought
they were crazy and now when we see
stories like this and how people are
having their heat turned off because
they're they're you know turning the
heat up too much
it really puts things into a perspective
that i think is worth considering
especially with how technology is being
more involved in our everyday lives and
how central controllers are using it to
track trace and data it's kind of
amazing you know they say climate change
and all that stuff you got to buy
electric cars and electric cars are
really bad for the environment
so uh yeah i i got a tesla we went to a
supercharger and i plug it in and i'm
sitting there and i'm looking at the
cost and it was like
it was half the cost of gas half like
you think it's going to be cheap not
only did it take 20 minutes to recharge
the car but we ended up spending i think
it was like 20 bucks to like fill up to
like recharge and i was like okay well
that's cheaper than gas but it's still
i'm pulling up to a gas station plugging
in spending 20 bucks on my credit card i
was like what what's the advantage here
then i can't go that far and the
government can now turn my car off
whenever they want nice do you feel do
you feel that it's people that genuinely
believe in climate change and genuinely
believe in
the the the future of the world being
overheated or do you feel like this is
just power driven i don't know man i
think this is going into there's a big
agenda in the un 2030 vision which is
also pictured by the buildback better
great reset world economic forum vision
they share the same vision it's
essentially the same thing they just
kind of rebrand it for marketing
purposes and their vision is of course
getting rid of cars and if you look at
major cities and the way that they've
been developing they've been getting rid
of people's ability to drive cars when
you drive a car you have freedom you
have the ability to go anywhere you want
they they want people stuck in cities
dependent on public transportation
essentially that is the end goal that
they are reaching for because then you
could have total enslavement of people
that can't escape that can't run away
and when you look at their their goals
they they they're they're already
implementing it it's not cost effective
to have a car in new york city insurance
rates are crazy speed cameras everywhere
you go roads are being turned into
pedestrian sidewalks traffic jams are
absolutely crazy and i think you know
there's there's there's a there's a big
portion of individuals who want to get
rid of cars because it's bad for the
environment but there's also a lot of
people who want to control people and
they're such control freaks that they
want to get rid of your ability to be
able to travel yeah
well it's very american like the idea of
the automobile right like detroit and
muscle cars and the interstate and just
being able to have that mobility and
that freedom to go exactly and it's it's
so i'm wondering like you know because i
i don't know what the elites the powers
that be really think do they really
believe that cars are killing the planet
or is it just making
people believe that cars are killing the
planet in order to have power over them
for me
no no go ahead go no so for me it's like
this more than anything is an indictment
on the centralization of public
education
because the fact of the matter is like
you know
a lot of people legitimately think it's
unfathomable or inconceivable
that our government will have
you know doesn't have our best interest
in mind and so to the extent that a
government like you know in switzerland
would you know
crack down on the way in which people
kind of regulate the temperature in
their home
rather than thinking of this as a kind
of tyrannical thing
many people unfortunately think of this
as the government having our best
interest in mind and so you know it for
me it is leading up to luke's point to
kind of a globalist agenda i mean for
example with you know king charles kind
of taking the throne in england he did
talk about climate change and he said
that this is an issue that can't be
fixed by a singular country
it can only be fixed by a coming
together of all the nations and so this
is kind of like a
rhetoric that's leading to
uh the kind of groundwork or the
threshold of a kind of globalist agenda
you know what i mean and so um hopefully
i didn't mess with the algorithm but um
that's definitely what they're building
up toward you know yeah
they can turn your car off whenever they
want and drive it wherever they want to
yeah so so that's crazy because you hear
about people in these random car
accidents right oh but now with like
tesla for instance you'll be like
sitting in your car and you'll be
driving and then
you know a warrant will come out for
your arrest or something like let's say
you were uh you you
are accused of doing something you
didn't do whatever you stole a package
or something like that you didn't do it
but they show a warrant for your arrest
because of it you're driving in your car
and all of a sudden it goes
and then it's like sorry dave you're
being detoured to the local police
station
and then it's like auto locks engaged
please sit back and remain calm and then
your car just slows down and turns
around you're like what i you can't get
out pulls up to the police station
they're out there waiting with their
guns ready and out of the vehicle your
car just arrested you for us
yeah i believe there's already stories
of of people's teslas being repossessed
by using the feature where the car
drives to you i i summon summoned to to
people repossessing them i need to do
research on that but i remember hearing
about that months ago specifically but
this is why you always have a glass
breaker uh wherever whenever you can for
that possibility that distinction but i
i do think there's multiple layers here
there's the environment level there's
the control level but there's also
trying to get them in
the model s is a cabin camera
so not only do they have cameras
surrounding the vehicle and it's
convenient it's because with so uh
parking and such yeah when you park you
can pull up the app and then you can
take a look and see the cameras from
anywhere because it connects to the cell
network and then you connect to the
network and then you're good so you can
park your car you can be in another
state and you can pull up your car's
cameras but they also have a cabin
camera i don't i don't know if all of
them have the center the model s has it
filming you yep and it's going to the
internet it's going to tesla's servers
now you can choose to watch it but it
means they're getting that footage too
and so it's a convenience it's that way
when you're driving you have the dash
cam and the cabin camera if you can do
an accident then we all know what
happened and also they know exactly what
you're doing whenever and they can
subpoena you may you may be thinking
yeah but tesla's not going to get it to
the government they will when they're
told they have to yeah when when some
fbi agent goes to someone says we want
to look inside their car right now and
then it does and then you're driving in
your vehicle and they and they decide
your car just stops the doors lock you
can't get out here's here's the other
thing the model s has the biohazard
filter mode or whatever where it like
seals the air and then blasts you with
like 99.99
filtered air then you're really locked
in then you can't get out well i always
thought it was strange like you know
because i don't really know where elon
musk is at you know i haven't done a lot
of research on him
but it's like this idea of like you know
turning your home solar putting a tesla
battery grid in your home
that charges your car
and then your car is actually becomes
your wi-fi right yeah as you're
connected to the starling satellites and
your brain chip is activated so
you're looking at one company that now
controls your your your energy
your transportation and your
communication yeah you know i mean the
minds but it's just like you know and i
know a lot of people kind of get on the
elon musk you know i i haven't like
again i haven't done a lot of research
in them but that's a lot of power to
give to one company well hold on how
cool would it be if neural link comes
out and you can get a brain implant
thing that can you know you put you
click your your chip into your brain and
then you can learn all the stuff but
then what ends up actually happening is
you know all of a sudden everyone like
they put it on and they go no what i
love elon musk i am one with musk and
then we're like fighting off zombies and
they're like join the musk and you're
like no then everyone's like they're
trying to put the implant in your neck
be one one with us and then elon's like
i am in charge now you are all my
children and then we're you know that's
just the reality that's that would be a
good we should make a movie we should
make a a sci-fi horror i did like the
photograph that uh the meme that was a
gas powered generator charging a tesla
in california this week that was really
funny
yeah cuz what are you gonna do there's a
there's a funny babylon bee thing where
it's like
uh california makes you charge your car
by hamster wheel or whatever like
it's it's especially funny when you
understand i believe the second law of
thermodynamics in that you're better off
just running somewhere instead of trying
to run to charge the car to drive the
car somewhere but i suppose the idea is
if you run for like 40 hours you'll have
enough to bring your groceries back from
the grocery store or something like that
there's another company i'm trying to
find right now that that is also
launching its own auto drive feature and
to do it they have a camera uh on the
driver who's driving the car to make
sure that his eyes are on the road and
his hands are on the wheel and if
they're not it it auto takes off the the
you know auto driver what's the point of
auto driving if the car can't auto drive
you know what's really annoying is it is
in the honda they have i think most new
cars have this they have the lane assist
thing and so you're driving and then
you'll see like uh like a skunk or
something oh i gotta go a little to the
left and it goes
like leaving the lane it freaks out and
then forces you back yeah i'm like dude
don't take the wheel from me trying to
not hit the turtle that was trying to
cross the street you know turtles are
going all slow and what are you supposed
to do just run it over yeah it's
definitely scary that they can they can
shut off your car and and have that kind
of power over you so yeah that's why i'm
really excited i'm looking into uh cars
from the 60s yeah yeah yep well it does
mine they're cheaper too yeah they might
have probably been legal at one point
right i mean that's the whole point yeah
again it's like america and the american
spirit is kind of a car culture you know
we are a mobile society like we you know
we really
um innovated cars and and and in the
interstate you know this the idea of
having the freedom to hit the road you
know kind of like the jack kerouac kind
of spirit of just going around the
country but now you're seeing more like
live work spaces mass transit
pods pods yeah all right let's let's get
into some social justice stuff oh boy
the very important story from the daily
mail oh yeah scooby-doo's velma it's a
karen oh my popular video game
multiverses hold on there that's fake
news i don't know if that game's popular
removes calling the police as sleuths
special power
because it's racist when she reports
lebron james's space jam character
well all right so lebron james in the
video game and a video went viral
because velma's super power is to call
the police and then the police car takes
you in the back and then like drives you
off a cliff and so people were laughing
that the cops were arresting lebron
james or whatever so here's what they
did
because it was racist
overnight i guess it randomly changed
i should say randomly but they changed
the cop car to the mystery machine and i
kind of felt like this is a really good
example of what's happening with defund
the police when when initially you have
the police being called and they arrest
the person when everyone gets angry the
cops are being called they replace it
with a panel van that kidnaps you and
drives you off a cliff so as we're
seeing crime skyrocketing in all of
these cities
after defund the police and abolish the
place and all that stuff i just thought
it was kind of funny but uh this is a
great this is great you know velma's
racist uh how are you guys doing what
did the lebron do to deserve this that's
in the video game that's what i want to
do
oh well like so you know it's a fighting
game so lebron's he's over here you know
striking a woman how dare he and then
velma calls the cops which is the right
thing you're supposed to do and then
everybody got mad about it so now now
instead of calling the cops she calls
her her goon squad to bring their van
and throw you in the back of it and
drive you off a cliff that's the game so
do they throw lebron in the van yes okay
yeah so like the characters in the game
i don't know if they show the characters
but like tom and jerry are in it and
there's like you know batman and
superman and actually actually i really
want to give props to it because it is
really funny because like it's a bunch
of warner bros characters
and then in the in the promo for it's
like bugs bunny and but shaggy he has
like a sandwich and they actually made
shaggy do karate and
fly and like power up like goku it's
actually really funny but i i do think
as a video game making your move call
the police is kind of dumb
but the point i wanted to make here is
look in every scooby-doo episode this is
what they do
they their car breaks down
for some reason and then there's a guy
in a costume dressed up like a ghost or
a zombie or something to scare people
away to lower property values that's
that's like the plot of every scooby-doo
episode and then once they finally
realize it's not really a monster it's
some dude they call the police and the
police take care of it but now you can't
have that
like that's racist it's offensive
we can't allow it so we have to remove
police because of the whims of the
social justice warriors is it racist
just because in that instance it was
against lebron james like if bugs bunny
was thrown in jail
do we have them
it's still racist
really that's what people are saying
they're saying that look look this guy
says this
he says i am enjoying velma and
multiverses but many a character whose
special move is calling the police on
her enemies definitely don't sit right
with me as a black man oh my goodness
that's it you can't like she's holding
up the picture of a white dude
but it's still wait so a black man wrote
this article no no this this this
comment right here was written by a
bloke
so yeah so speaking of that comment like
for me like
my
question to that
that guy who wrote that tweet is have
you no shame
because the thing is like you know as a
black man
um
i'm not willing to
temporarily play the victim or to make
myself look so weak
and so
fragile
uh over a game
that i'm willing to in a sense kind of
thrust this kind of social justice
agenda along like i'm not gonna i'm not
going to to to to placate or to to
basically put this image of myself out
there as this kind of victim so as to
push this agenda like i'm i just have
too much pride i guess but i'm just not
willing to do that but the the the issue
for me when it comes to stuff like this
is
you know how how are so-called people of
color like how do they not have any kind
of shame
at all
and making themselves look so weak that
we need culture to modify itself like to
accommodate us scooby-doo has been
around for what 50 years
is that how long scooby-doo's been i
don't know
and it always ends okay not every single
time but overwhelmingly every episode
that ends with the police coming in and
arresting the guy and then fred's like
let's see who it really was and then
they pull the mask off and it's like
it's john murphy or something like that
but see i'm wondering how much of this
is the media to like find this one tweet
this one guy and then put it out and fan
it you know what i mean it's like it
could easily have been ignored like are
people really upset about this but the
game changed it yeah so this tweet i
think is from like a month ago wow you
know and he makes like a passive comment
that's kind of like haha isn't it funny
and and nobody cares but then the people
who make the game actually went in and
changed it
that's crazy yeah you can't have a
culture that's like you call the police
when there's a problem yeah right luke
uh a little conflicted on this one
i'll be honest here uh i was debating
how i should introduce this topic here
to this conversation
i mean
there's a lot of ridiculousness to me
this is just a distraction to me this is
this is this is the ethos of a declining
civilization this is absolutely
ridiculous that we're even talking about
this there's a lot of things you could
say about the police there's a lot of
things you could talk about holding
power accountable but this is not it why
is velma fighting anyway yeah you know i
was like of all the characters shaggy i
get
shaggy it's actually really funny seeing
him fight because he's a coward in the
cartoon
and so the gag i guess is that he's like
freaking out like what's happening man
then someone knocks his sandwich out of
his hands and then he just goes insane
with rage that's actually funny i like
that like that but velma like why is she
fighting i'd like to see velma fight
lebron james i think that would be
entertaining
well you can it's in the game that's
what the game is and why is lebron james
even in it yeah
you know what you know
yeah but you know what's funny i wonder
if lebron realized he'd be selling his
likeness to games like this when he did
the movie they're like oh yeah we might
make a video game based on or
something's like yeah okay that's cool
and he's thinking it's gonna be like
sometimes i wonder if lebron knows what
he's doing any of the time yeah yeah
some of the things that he's he said in
public so yeah he's definitely
demonstrated that he's willing to play
the puppet in many uh scenarios so but
for what
that's the thing like
for what reason are people willing to to
bend the knee is it for food
for money i just think i don't know but
i mean like what does money get you what
do you do with it because you want an
infinity pool or something i got to tell
you man it's not that great what money
is is a is a huge idol
in the so-called black community i mean
if you look at excuse me if you look at
like a lot of the
the music that's coming out right now
we're glorifying money you know i'm
saying so it's like
in a sense we're kind of imparting to
the youth who are consuming this
uh medium
that these are the things to prioritize
these are the things to strive for and
to to
you know work toward you know i'm saying
it doesn't matter whether or not the
means by which you
work you know pursue it are honest or
dishonest
it's just at the end of the day this is
what makes you something this is what
makes you
prominent and powerful um
it's unfortunate but you know
it is what it is well i think for like
lebron um
it's just a lack of knowledge like he
doesn't really know um
a lot of history he doesn't really know
what's going on and
i think there's also a lot of guilt put
on certain people that are in his
caliber of wealth you know if you're
black and you're successful and you've
made it
you're there's a lot of guilt that you
want to like you know look back you know
look at the people and help the people
so well the way to do that is to
yeah to play the play the woke and play
the the victim play the the race card
well the the thing about lebron is like
lebron comes from a
uh household that was you know lower
income he grew up with just his mother
in the home
and i would i would venture to say and i
say this not because i know lebron i say
this because i know a lot of people who
were in similar situations is
they have resolved that because i grew
up in such
uh a distressed situation i'm going to
see to it that my children
don't
in a sense suffer the same things that
i've had to suffer growing up and so i
want to in a sense basically uh
envelop them in this life of of plenty
and privilege and so for lebron like
he's very much about like his status
he's very much about like in a sense uh
leveling up and he wants to kind of
create this lineage and so he's going to
seize every opportunity that comes along
and so the question becomes
to what extent do you apply principles
to what it is you're doing and so i
don't want to i don't want to add to
this you know what i mean and i mean
it's
selling your likeness to a video game
you know who who would have known that
it would have come to this you know what
i mean so i don't want to speculate but
at the same time
um
you know
lebron had nothing to do with this it's
just a matter of people like like woke
yet again
coming to
get another like extreme kind of degree
so to speak i think i think this is a
part of uh
there is an element of woke i guess the
woke
they're chasing after
nothing
it's like
we talk about these algorithms on
youtube where they started making the
incredible hulk fight hitler but hitler
had a woman's body and was doing tai chi
while it's saying a nursery rhyme and
the reason those videos emerged was
because the algorithm was just trying to
figure out what got play and what got
clicks and i feel like that's what
leftist ideology is
that's why it's random it makes no sense
that's why they're like we oppose
fascism and support the fbi raiding our
political opponents like how what you
they're just saying whatever
algorithmically plays there's no leader
there's no rhyme or reason and this is
one of those things
there's a cop
because it's what scooby-doo does and so
they're like oh i can be i can be mad
about that that that fits in the mold of
the algorithm so you have this
decentralized network of lunatics who
are just
filling the holes of whatever it is
could possibly make you angry and fit
their ideology well there's two
possibilities here one someone is
extremely privileged and has a huge
victim mentality that is being promoted
by big tech social media or someone's
trolling i think there's a big
possibility someone's like i'm just
going to troll this company and for the
company this this mega corporation that
created this video game to cave that
that that really is the big l here that
really is something that that is worth
talking about because
we could just do absurd stuff on the
internet and they'll respond and they'll
and they'll edit and they'll it react to
us i think that element is also
important to understand here and the
more that corporations cave the more
they're opening themselves up to trolls
and i think there might be a possibility
that this is a troll fantastic point
this is well
exactly that's that's that's the big l
there that's that's the big eye-opening
situation that that is worth talking
about but to justin's point about like
you know and to your point too luke
about how much of this is either
trolling or just the media kind of
assert
you know assisting on a certain
narrative
it does have ramifications in the real
society you know what i'm saying and my
my concern is that it's kind of
instilling in the youth of of black
people and other so-called people of
color this kind of paranoia and this
kind of entitlement that society owes me
something it needs to modify itself to
accommodate me it needs to walk on
eggshells around me because i'm so
fragile and i'm so
insecure in myself
that if you know
the image of a man regardless of what
his color is
beating up a woman
on a video game and that woman calling
the police on that man
which in any other scenario is the
proper thing to do is considered racist
it's just so backwards in
in
in
irritating in my opinion well let's talk
about uh your guys's movie uncle tom too
yeah what's uh what's it about what's
going on i saw the first one
and uh i learned a lot about herman cain
and he was uh he was a badass that was
awesome
yeah
so you know uncle tom
one
we'll call it uncle one was uh
really
turned out to be kind of a conservatism
101.
you know i start i started the film just
out of a
curiosity of you know why black america
when it came to conservative black
america
was treated in such a way and i think
around 2015 2016
during that
cultural climate
the hypocrisy was very real for me
in 2012 herman cain
you know was running for president
and you know i supported herman cain i
thought he was great and two years prior
to that you know or i'm sorry a couple
years prior to that
you know if you didn't support barack
obama you were a racist and so literally
like you know one political cycle later
a black man from the south
from atlanta georgia runs for president
and
he was you know
a [ __ ] and uncle tom all the things the
media completely destroyed him and that
shocked me because at the time i'd never
seen the media talk about a black man
that way because by that time we were
already on eggshells
so that kind of started the the the
wanting to make the film
and then
as i started interviewing black
conservatives it kind of just opened up
this entire world to me
and i realized there was a lot of
diversity there was a lot of different
uh walks of life within the black
conservative movement and on that
journey i met chad jackson who was one
of the people i interviewed for the film
and he actually became the main
subject of of the first film
and during that time
you know we became pretty close friends
and when the film released and it was
you know we had some success and it was
very well received and
we were riding the wave of that
um i realized that there was more work
to be done there was a there was more
story to tell and so i asked chad
to come on board with me and um
so
give us a synopsis on the first one then
tell us about the first the first one i
would say was conservatism 101 we called
it an oral history of the american black
conservatives basically just
establishing the fact that not all black
people are far left democrats that not
all black people hate america that not
all black people view themselves as
victims in america
and i kind of think that
uh
i would imagine
the the stereotype i guess of the black
community in the church is that they're
more conservative outright but for some
reason keep voting with democrats they
are and i think part two as we you know
part two gets more into the historical
lineage of
what happened to black america and
during during the process you know it we
take it all the way back to marx you
know uh when our country is on fire a
couple years ago during the the blm
chaos
there was an interview that patrice
cullers you know slipped up and told the
world that she was a trained marxist
and so people sort of like what does
that mean
and what is this world view that's got
my country on fire
so uncle tom two
goes to karl marx explains who he was
explains what he believed
in his ideology and how it made its way
into america
and
and how america had to be
um
transformed slowly gradually because of
our history because of our individual
spirit marxism didn't really work in
america it worked in the east it spread
like fire in the east but in the west it
marks marxism was harder to sell
well it's been gaining a foothold across
the board in a variety of fashions and
for america it's taken a little over 100
years to get where we are
and as we zoom into
marxism
you find that black america was the
low-hanging fruit for that ideology to
take hold
and to
use black america as its tool for
destruction in our country yeah i like
so from our perspective and justin's 100
percent uh right
for me what uncle tom 2 does is it
showcases this era of black prosperity
that we're not we're not
traditionally told about in the
mainstream media and when i say
mainstream media i'm talking about uh
organizations like npr which is
constantly putting out you know stories
of black america as they see it and it
it's constantly depicting black america
as being oppressed as being under the
thumb of the white man as being
hated by this country but what we found
when we dug into you know to the
archives is that black america
was thriving
in the 1900s from the early 19 to the
mid 1900s
not uh in spite of
the white south but in some cases with
the help of the white south and so what
we found is that race relations between
white and black in the south were
actually far more harmonious
than
uh kind of oppressive like we're
constantly told about and so we're able
to show these these beautiful
uh
photos and and just this footage
of things that are not just frankly
talked about in the mainstream media and
to the extent that they do talk about it
it's always kind of uh
tainted with this kind of of oppressive
message that is meant to
constantly remind black people that you
are oppressed this country hates you and
because this country hates you you need
to vote this way you need to think this
way you need to
in a sense be entitled and so
it's offering a different perspective if
you will the film also shows how to the
extent that you have these so-called
black organizations like the naacp like
black lives matter like these
organizations that are all about
blackness asserting blackness when you
lift up the veil when you pull back the
curtain what you find
behind these so-called black
organizations
are white marxists yep and so
it's important to showcase that because
this whole like you know this whole
pejorative of uncle tom
it's meant to
silence individuals like herman cain
like larry elder
like thomas sowell because if you listen
to thomas soul if you listen to larry
elder if you listen to alan west you'll
find that these guys actually know what
the heck they're talking about
and to the extent that people apply what
it is they're saying
they will be benefited not only as black
folks but as people in general and so
you don't want such a man to have a kind
of effect on the masses of people let
alone black people and so you want to in
a sense demonize them and ostracize them
and make them look as a kind of parasite
amongst the masses of black people so
you're going to call them this
pejorative you know uncle tom [ __ ] book
look or sell out so on and so forth
because you want to silence them so we
we demonstrate that to the extent that
these so-called black liberal activists
are using these pejoratives they
themselves
are having their puppet strings pulled
by who
white marxists and so at the end of the
day i don't care
whether ideology is coming from a white
person or black person i don't care
because race isn't that important to me
but to the extent that i can expose
that the people behind these so-called
black you know pro-black individuals are
actually white marxists once we can get
that out of the way then we can have a
conversation about what actually matters
and what actually matters is ideology
and what kind of manifestations does
ideology have on the way in which people
are actually living and whether or not
people are prospering or whether they're
constantly failing baltimore is an
example of how we're felling under
marxism
detroit is an example of how we're
actually felling under marxism outside
of chicago all these organizations are
i'm sorry cities are examples of how
we're felling under our marxism we went
your way we applied your policies we
applied what it is you're pushing what
it is you're selling and black people
are not being benefited by it and so
these are yeah these these woke leftists
they're the same kind of people that
were pro-slavery they're the same kind
of people that just want the status quo
and they and they're hiding behind the
revolutionary ideas but but it's not the
case yeah there was a story like the
site where a teacher asked his students
how many of you
would have opposed slavery in the time
of the american civil war and all the
kids raised their hand he's like oh okay
so tell me something that you'll
publicly admit to supporting that's
deeply unpopular and you know incites
anger and hatred and they don't have
anything to say the point was that most
of these kids were just doing whatever
they thought would get them to fit in
and when you look at you know i remember
reading about frederick douglass and he
challenged americans to to live by the
standard of their own constitution the
words that they wrote and swear and
swear allegiance to
will they uphold that all men are
created equal that these rights exist
for everybody and then a bunch of got
pissed off at them a bunch of white
racists those are the people who are
like don't you screw with what i got
the left thinks that they're
revolutionaries but they're supporting
the corporations they're supporting the
fbi they're supporting the government
and its policies and its machine and
they're demonizing i'll give you an
example anti-fuzz the perfect example of
this this is who i think of
overwhelmingly white they know it they
love wearing masks because they don't
want anyone to realize it and i watched
white antifa scream at a black ice
officer the n-word and i've personally
witnessed
white antifa screaming the n-word at a
black proud boy
and i'm like those all of those antifa
they're all white every single one of
them and then over here on the proud boy
side like mexican guy and there's like a
filipino guy and there's a couple black
guys and there's a bunch of white guys
and i'm like isn't that so strange
that's the case there are people who
believe in individual liberties and
there are people who believe in just do
as the mob says or else yeah yeah you're
100 right and like that's like we depict
that in our film we talk about people
like saul alinsky we talk about who the
real kind of founder of black lives
matter is it is a white marxist like
people look at these you know three
black women and think like oh
um you know they started this
organization because of trayvon martin
and because of they're being fed up with
the police brutality that the police are
constantly
kind of dashing out against you know
black
you know
black and you know individuals who can't
protect themselves when in reality like
no that's not the case at all um it is a
white man who
subscribes to marxist ideology who is
training these people by his own
admission he says that i go after
uh women black and latino women i
trained them to be revolutionaries i
trained them to start organizations like
we depict that in this film and so one
of the things that we set out to do in
making uncle tom too is we didn't want
to in a sense regurgitate the same old
conservative talking points we wanted to
go deeper we wanted to show people where
this ideology is based out of and so
this film in my in my opinion is
superior to uncle tom too is in that in
the sense that we take people deeper
to see like where all this comes from so
as to not be constantly intimidated by
whatever social justice movement comes
along in a given era so so you're trying
to tell me when joe biden said you're
not black if you don't vote for him that
he was wrong
well i think one of the things i'm most
proud about about part two and in the
work that we've done is just really like
getting to
the core of america like what made
america
what made america was our our our world
view you know our our christian ethic
and you know being a moral people you
know
and
if you look at the history of marxism in
this country the number one goal was to
demoralize us as a people
and if you just take black america just
as a microcosm of america if you look at
the footage that we show you in this
film
black america
was a very prosperous very
entrepreneurial spirit uh very moral
people very church going very nuclear
family like all those things were were
happening for black america in the early
1900s
and
when you what what the marxists were
able to do was slowly demoralize
black america and now we're seeing the
effect of america at large is just to
take our
um
our morals away from us and create chaos
you know with with the christian
worldview that america was built on you
had order you know there was a
foundation there was a foundation in god
and and that created a a set of rules a
set of set of
a way to do things a way to do life
and that has been the the the goal and
the tactic to destroy our country is to
slowly chip away at those morals and
those values
and so i think in my opinion what we've
what we've put together an uncle tom too
really showcased that showcases how this
happened like no other film and i think
that you know what we're getting from
people that are watching it and writing
us
is that it really equips them it arms
them with the knowledge that they really
couldn't articulate themselves yeah it
gives them the ability to
um understand what they what they knew
but they couldn't articulate yeah and i
think that we've labored over this film
for the past two years to
you know because explaining marxism is
hard to do yeah it's very hard to do to
explain these ideas
you know the first film was much easier
to put together because conservatism is
pretty easy to explain
but marxism is rooted in deception so
it's hard to untangle that for people
and i feel people are are are expressing
expressing that uncle tom too is giving
them that uh confidence to talk about
these issues yeah in a nutshell like the
way that i'll explain it is like what
marxist understood tim
is that
um
to the extent that they wanted to
inject their ideology into the american
society they were having a very hard
time doing it because the culture that
existed in america was very antithetical
to the communist world view
and so
the fact of the matter is that culture
like how does cultures persist cultures
persist generationally through children
you instill in you know and impart your
culture to your children and then they
carry it on into the future and so what
the marxist resolve to do is that if we
can get into the
to the uh to the culture of the children
if we can in a sense uh cause them to
rebel against the adult generation
um to reject the culture of the adult
generation we can um in a sense inject
our culture and our society in our world
view into the youth to where
you know the trajectory of our country
is completely different and so when you
look at second wave feminism in the 60s
when you look at the hippie movement in
the 60s when you look at the free love
movement in the 60s when you look at the
civil rights movement when you look at
the black militant movement all of these
are rebellious to the adult generation
of the 60s and what they were able to do
was to demoralize a culture to where
they are rejecting the adult generation
and are adopting this kind of new world
view to the extent to where today
more young people under the age of 30
are embracing
socialism than any other youth
generation before in this country
that goes to that goes to show that what
yuri besmanov talks about
who was a defect
who who defected from the kgb it goes to
show that what he talked about actually
played out the way that he described it
and so yes this is something that has
taken place in our country uncle tom ii
uh describes it uh in a very palatable
way in a in a sense in a way that no
other film um
and
that i've seen have been able to to to
break it down so all right we're gonna
go to super chats if you haven't already
would you kindly smash the like button
subscribe to this channel and share the
show with your friends
head over to timcast.com become a member
we're gonna have a members only show
coming up at about 11 p.m but for now we
will just go to your super chats we got
jeff hill he says holy ish
tonight tim cast and door both hitting
on the real problems with food listen to
luke he's found the real rabbit hole
a lot of rabbit holes down there a lot a
bunch of different holes huh
keegan reese says tim hope you might
cover the looming railroad strike please
reach out to unions s m
utu and blet
or view their joint statements regarding
the cutting of jobs and horrible
attendance policy
well
we've been trying to build uh the new
location over at freedom stand labor
shortage supply shortage and we're a
year behind we commissioned the project
a year ago and they can't put together a
building it's it's absolutely remarkable
there's no people there's no materials
it takes forever it's just it's it's
insane what's going on
it's the end of days i guess raymond g
stanley jr says someone pinch me am i
dreaming or is the pierogi man himself
looking to sell me a t-shirt my stomach
hasn't been this full since june welcome
back luke thanks for having me
filled with pierogies and horse medicine
ready to go
all right sir doom says first time super
chatter long time listener i went to
find the show today and i couldn't find
the show on my youtube homepage
you must be right over target with these
discussions keep up the good fight yeah
something really interesting happened
on my two channels i have tim cast and
tim cass news different youtube channels
when i logged in my dashboard showed me
that my last videos didn't have any
views it was like 30 000 views and it
was like the worst video you've ever
made
the videos actually have hundreds of
thousands
and i'm like that's weird why are just
my two channels so we have other
channels at tim cast so we've got you
know cass castle and music and i looked
and they were totally normal this weird
thing only affected my two personal solo
like news channels so i have to wonder
if what that does is negatively impact
the channel and the algorithm so that it
doesn't get shared as much or something
like that
i can say that um
yeah
people don't get tim cast irl in their
homepages and youtube's also been doing
this thing where whenever we launch the
stream it does a gray box with no
thumbnail for some reason and so people
scrolling will just see nothing
it's amazing that that happens
because then people don't click the show
they don't see it they don't notice it
they keep scrolling they can't find it
it's funny how that works huh good job
youtube what did you do to get on their
backside
gee i wonder
andy welsh says red super chat literally
just because luke
well thank you well great great there
you go
what do we have here
recre morrison lemniskit says please
extend an invitation to pierre
paul liev the new conservative leader of
canada our best chance of throwing out
trudeau and the closest thing we have to
a desantis of the north cool desantis of
the north
i like that
yeah
scott nolan says tim did president trump
come to dc just to be on tim cast this
week and are you holding off on the
announcement luke welcome back
let's try to get him luke's popular
tonight i would love to question donald
trump
peter provenzano says i will pay a
one-year subscription at timcast.com to
be to be donated raffled away if luke is
allowed to go all out and discuss 9 11
and questions and theories on the after
show so we're actually planning on
putting together a show called uh well i
don't know what it's called but we're
putting together a show where we want to
bring people from different backgrounds
to sit down and have conversations now
it's going to be impossible to get like
a left winger and a right winger but
it's gonna be really easy to get like an
environmentalist and a petroleum
engineer so that kind of stuff is is
possible i think for a show like that
the idea is put this up sundays is a
members-only show we wanted to get like
a trans athlete and a female athlete to
have a conversation with each other yeah
i think those are really possible and
that's what we're planning on putting
together it'd be a good spot for luke to
uh have a conversation about all this
stuff i did a video about 9 11 yesterday
and it nuked my channel and the
algorithm you could watch that on uh
youtube.com we are change
yes i can only imagine that well i mean
youtube explicitly said those videos
would get nuked yeah that they're going
to try to stop people from this one got
mega nuked like bad
all right
what is this
darth kyra says everyone forget about
the rv bombing
what's that one was that the one at the
att building that was uh there was a
weird case of a rv exploding i thought
the fbi was investigating and then it
stopped investigating it and they didn't
find out who did it a couple christmases
it was yeah that was the att building
right i don't know if it was the att
building but i remember hearing about it
and seeing the video of the rv driving
and then the explosion yeah geez
kevin
kwanznazza says i'm an rn from nh having
a hard time finding work due to my flat
out refusal to get vaxxed i worked so
hard to be a nurse now my profession is
compromised of pawns peddling political
narratives and ignoring actual ethics
and evidence-based practice
um
i'm hearing like nurses are striking
and that the industry is collapsing like
nobody wants to be a nurse anymore i
mean you got friends lydia what are they
saying so
my friends are just like all about oh
you should get backstage do all this
stuff it's really important that
everyone get vaccinated but i
also know people in the industry who are
just they saw the worst of it and now
they're terrified so kind of makes sense
it'll be collapsing it's pretty
intimidating i know yeah same thing is
going on with pilots as well yeah yeah
man
so i just found out that you can get
like a small plane for like 60 grand and
that's that's kind of hefty but you
think about how much it costs to fly per
you know flying on like commercial for a
business i was like i think we spend
more on that
you know flying around for events we
just get our own plane yeah there you go
problem solved you can also get like a
share you know like you go in and you
can get uh private flights for you know
yeah you share with other corporate
heads yeah there's this thing that
people do
where you buy a percentage yeah and then
you fly like cost or whatever so it's
like a co-op but having your own plane
is just you know just another safety
barrier in these very difficult times
ahead of us true but i mean it's the
difference between between going 250
miles an hour and 700 miles an hour or
whatever the difference well so if you
if you get like a plane from the 60s
like they fly and you can act they're
actually like 20 grand or whatever so
it's like you think about it's like get
a car get a plane and for running a
business
being able to move around you know that
saves you money in the long run if
you're if you're a travel heavy business
yeah so i'm like at this point
definitely something i'm into for sure
having a pilot's license
yeah gotta get that
seth hauser says i think it should be
trump 2024 we need a wrecking ball
desantis has not fired anyone only
suspended i believe desantis will just
play politics with the uniparty i don't
think so but i do i do think trump is a
wrecking ball so point higging i don't
know what do you think luke um good
points made it's worth considering
because you know uh the the upbringing
of desantis is wreaking of establishment
we still don't know his foreign policy
and he did make some uh you know weird
moves when it came to uh you know the
the laws that are implemented in florida
so no one's perfect don't trust any
politician trust yourself amen yeah
augusto mimoshe says i was down with the
sanderson 2024 carl benjamin has a video
called it has to be trump that really
convinced me his story arc must be
complete completely completely closed
and they can't get away with what they
did to him
yeah that's what carl benjamin was
saying that trump's narrative isn't
complete like there has to be
some finale right
perhaps well desantis is a young man so
i mean he has time so
maybe it's better to let him develop a
little bit but i don't know if trump is
is damaged goods at this point with how
much
he's gone through so yeah talbot link
says tim got to see dropkick murphy's
live recently
there was an angry rant involving a maga
hat on stage the audience was so full of
hate not just anger that it scared me as
bad as being in a big city riot it's
getting worse perhaps i think i saw that
rant it went viral and the guy from the
dropkick murphys is a zealot who doesn't
know how to use google
he was basically saying they're just a
bunch of rich people and if you vote for
them they just want tax cuts it's okay
well donald trump gave a tax cut to the
middle class so sure rich people got
corporations got tax cuts too that's
that's for sure but uh the democratic
party is the party of the wealthy
numerous studies and stories have
pointed this out going back to 2016 the
democrats overtook the republicans in
2016 to be the party of the wealthy and
get this
when polled
people who make under 100 000 a year
overwhelmingly do not want donald trump
to have i'm sorry they overwhelmingly
want joe biden to be impeached and
people who make more than a hundred
thousand tend to not want joe biden to
be impeached so it's funny how that
plays out
the largest portion of people defending
biden were salaries over two hundred
000. yeah hilarious
so uh good for the anti-punk we should
call we should call it anti-punk it's
probably best way to put it because it's
not like you know you know anti-racism
is like racism of a different flavor
yeah yeah anti-punk they're still kind
of punk but they're they're like
you know pro machine punk so you know
how you talk about how these
institutions are being worn like skin
suits i think punk is definitely an
example of this for sure by the way i
have to apologize for my camera
switching just a second ago because i
was using my left hand and we gave the
chair some time on the air everyone's
cheering for the chair my apologies but
i think punk is very much i feel like
they were the first symptom of this
happening because i remember in high
school in like 2008 i was like why do
they call themselves punk if they're
actually in favor of big government and
my you know boyfriend at the time could
not explain it there's no answer yeah
well a couple years ago there was
nothing more punk rock than to wear a
maga hat out in public right i mean if
you really want to be a punk rocker like
that was the way to do it isn't the guy
from like rage like it's a machine like
all about like you know yeah government
government yeah i'm sorry i believe they
changed their name to rage on behalf of
them
that's correct
make sense they had me duped man yeah
yeah
yup they are the machine that's what i
was saying i went to a skate park and
black lives matter was tagged on like
the
the ramp and i saw some kids hanging out
they started laughing and i was like who
tagged the walmart logo
and i was like how lame is that i was i
was leaving our studio uh last night and
someone uh
spray painted beto22
and i said what a appropriate political
ad graffiti of your uh of beta right
there on the wall
chris van durham says with carrie lake
and mtg being standouts of this new wave
of ultra maga republicans could you
imagine if republicans elect the first
female potus l.o.l i would not be
surprised if that was the case
the first uh the first black member of
congress was a rebel republican i
believe yeah yeah
and it was like not till like 150 years
later the democrat finally elected a a
democratic
elected a black person yeah yeah but
yeah they're the champions of you know
civil rights and the black man so
you know they they they're they're the
champions of messaging i guess yes oh
they are you know masters of messaging
they're genius bravo yeah
matthew johnson says tim off subject i
am going through a hard time i don't cry
a lot but tonight i needed it only ever
wanted has helped a lot thanks for what
you do don't worry it is just life
giving me the toss around thank you i
appreciate it man only ever wanted of
course is a song that we released uh
august 26th so you check it out on
spotify add will of the people and only
ever wanted your playlist playlist and
just listen to them all the time because
it's good it helps and uh listen to our
music it's the best thing i can say and
also shout out to tom mcdonald riot has
been sitting on the itunes list top 100
at number two riot is his new song from
last week and we're hoping that he hits
number one on that 100.
it's a feat i gotta be honest i really
don't i don't think we can get it but
let's help out tom mcdonald so check out
his song riot see you know buy it if you
can on amazon or itunes and if he does
hit number one we're all gonna wear
suits
luke's gonna wear a suit
a pimp suit
he bent the rules we were like we're
gonna wear suits and looks like i can
wear any suit i was like yes luke and he
says i'm gonna wear a pimp suit i'm like
purple are you going perfectly
technically i'm gonna go neon green nice
you do look you look great in a seat tim
that would be great yeah and ian wearing
a suit would be great we'll make him put
his hair up or something and then we'll
get luke a big purple hat and a cane or
something like that
but you got like a jerry girl
[Laughter]
only if tom mcdonald hits number one all
right getting there only number one
dave pearce photography says i was in
the pit photographing adelita's way and
guess who i saw tim and ian check your
fb messages for a pick more if you want
oh hey look at that
uh yeah so we were down at um blue ridge
rock fest over the weekend hanging out
with all the remains and adelita's way
and you know the crazy thing is this is
a huge rock fest
it was crowding how many people tens of
thousands maybe a hundred thousand
people just nuts and there's a bunch of
different stages we saw tenacious d
the draw for tenacious d was so intense
that artists
production crew and media were trying to
squeeze in front of the stage like this
is a security area where some people can
stand but they had to call the police
and not for the actual attendees but for
staff because everybody want to see jack
black and tenacious d so bad but what i
will say is
major white pill going to this event
so we go there
and i'm like i don't know what to expect
right i don't know where these rock
bands are of course we're good friends
with phil labonte of all that remains
he's red we're gonna have him on the
show again soon he's been on the show a
couple of times and uh adelita's way uh
they're awesome dudes their fans we're
fans of theirs and so we get to hang out
with them
and then also some dude comes up to me
from one band and i'm gonna you know
i'm gonna leave their names out of it
but they were one of the bands playing
up on stage this big festival and he was
like i agree with everything you say man
your show is awesome and i was like oh
wow thanks dude i'm standing down on the
ground in front of jack black you know
tenacious d and one of the other bands
he's like dude we're big fans we love
what you do and i'm like at this rock
show
people listen and they care and they pay
attention so that's like a major white
pill because there were tons of people
there and everybody was super cool we
met a bunch of really awesome people so
that's awesome yeah i think you just got
to not believe like the media
exactly exactly it's amazing to me how
great of a voice jack black has
you know i know he's so good that was
nuts my mind was blown they their
performance live was was amazing yeah it
was good stuff i recommend it man i
really do i don't know but politics or
anything all i know is the whole set was
amazing and the crazy thing is too
tenacious d the pick of destiny flopped
the box office but i'm looking at a
crowd of thousands of people all singing
kickapoo and i was like they all know
the words and then i was like man wow
that's that's my crowd you know we i i
love that movie yeah do you get that a
lot where people come to you that you
wouldn't expect that that supports you
and support the show
i mean
i people come to me off like all the
time you know i'll be out somewhere
we're like eating at a restaurant
someone comes with me we're at a gas
station and some guy walked over like
we're in the gas station we're in a gas
station in clarksville virginia middle
now and some guy's like hey it's tim and
i'm like yo what's up and nice to meet
you but what's crazy is you know i had
some people telling warning me like hey
it's a rock festival so there's going to
be some woke bands you never know and
they're going to get really angry so
just you know you never know if someone
but no every single person that i met
that knew who i was was like we love
your show man awesome to see you here
so yeah it just goes to show that
there's a lot there's a lot more people
that are awake than than we would be led
to believe yep
and that's and and i think it uh uh
i don't know i think it's a it's a
positive reflection that
so many people at this big rock festival
this big crowd i was kind of like man i
didn't realize how many people here
would probably know who i was and maybe
i should
not be walking around in the open areas
and stuff like that need security or
something just man up guys and come out
with it like let's do this thing you
know
i mean everybody there was speaking up
you know it was it was really cool
especially the guys from adelita's way
they're they're outspoken as outspoken
can get so we're going to have them out
where that's going to be really cool
that's coming soon yeah rick from
eddie's way that dude can sing oh
they're so mind-blowing
yeah it's always refreshing going to
like a show where the
uh artist isn't like just completely
just woke or just come you know using
the show as like a kind of platform to
reinforce their
liberal woke
jargon i mean i went to a fleet fox's
show recently in dallas
and like he was just such a pleasant
dude you know i mean like he didn't
bring politics in it he was just a
genuinely nice guy that was just
very enjoyable to watch so right on yeah
dd mega doo doo okay says talking about
pizza hut roofing their crust as i'm
running a train on on side leftovers
great username by the way papa john's
man i was surprised i won't order uh
from anywhere else and it's not just
that it's like even small local joints
they'll use like brominated flour and
then you look at papa john's they don't
nice yeah it's too bad they they got
woke and you know i remember when i was
like i'm not gonna order from that
anymore because what they did to to papa
john cause he's a good dude and
but you know
gotta gotta admit it they they do have
better ingredients that's for sure
canola oil is everywhere and that stuff
is horrible seed oil
what do you use
olive oil um butter
cereal cow oil yeah cow
butter and ghee
mason wolfie says your best friend this
winter is a good wood stove no power
cooking the wood stove cold fire up the
wood stove
brought to you from rural oregon yeah i
told my family in poland i'm like a
couple months ago i'm like get a wooden
stove right now go chop wood right now
um they didn't listen oh you're polished
yeah well i was born and raised in
poland yeah chopping wood is fun though
man yeah
yeah we did that in new hampshire too
because we have a wood splitter it's
also fun
it's a different kind of fun you know
it's a thing where the piston goes back
and forth and you put the log in then it
crushes it yeah but actually taking the
accident
it's a lot of fun yeah do you do you
speak fluent in polish nice yep
that's why he mispronounces other words
you know that's why i get an excuse for
butchering english
which i use all the time
that guy 1678 says what do you all think
about mastercard visa and amex coming
out and now tracking gun purchases
horrible horrifying horrible
absolutely disgusting behavior that of
course is going to
lead to people being put on a list that
are going to be given to governments and
also more importantly probably are going
to be hacked and then people will have
people's information about who actually
has a weapon and doesn't which is very
dangerous for everyone involved here
when are they implementing implementing
um this was pushed on by a new york
politician um
i think i think they're going to be
implementing it automatically i don't
know exactly when but so discover is
good uh visa mastercard american express
are part of this program so so discover
is that it looks like discovery all
right we're making discovery a thing
parallel economy man we're getting
discover cards was that voluntary like
they volunteered to be part of this or
was this this was a politician saying
they should do this and they said yes
all right i'm gonna say it right now
discover
i will sign up for discover and we will
use it for our business if you don't do
this this is your opportunity that's
right with these companies coming after
our second amendment rights discover
every gun person you know
we should fact check to see if discover
is doing this right now
but you want to google it real quick if
they're not doing it i say the the
entirety of the two-way commit community
make discover the new thing great idea
yeah yeah yeah this is gonna be like
we're back we've got a whole bunch of
customers you know so absolutely i'll
put my whole business on discover as
well on the whole guardian
let's do it i love that joke from
futurama where he's like do you take
visa like visa hasn't been around for a
thousand years mastercard 2000 and he's
like discover oh we don't take discover
all right i got the years wrong but you
get the point
he's like 500 years i mean i'm all for
like you know politician or i'm sorry uh
companies
operating on their own volition even if
it means complying to
uh you know radical bizarre government
you know policies but at the same time
you know you would hope that these
organizations these companies
would be in favor of our constitutional
rights instead of infringing upon them
you know yeah bank of america said that
they wouldn't support any kind of loans
to gun manufacturers so there's a lot of
big banking institutions that of course
allow jeffrey epstein to bank and break
the rules and do whatever he wanted to
money launder in order to run an
international trafficking operation of
children that's okay by by you know
brown brothers and harriman goldman
sachs and all these other big chase
manhattan and all these other big
players but uh people being able to
defend themselves no is discover
i'm looking at it right now i'm looking
at a forum i'm doing research on this
right now all right because i want to
make sure because if they are doing it i
don't wanna we do not prohibit legal gun
sales said katie henry a spokesperson
for uh spokeswoman for discovery there
you go are they tracking it uh that's
the question they do not prohibit it i'm
reading about it right now well
of those who said they are gonna it's a
visa mastercard and amex they will track
gun purchases
yes those are the three that officially
announced all right discover it is
ladies and gentlemen let's spread the
word i'm gonna make some phone calls
afterwards get gotta call some other
person guys discover it's happening i
gotta call up the local gun shops and be
like get discovered cause we're not
using visa i got to be honest i bet a
lot of the shops have already started
thinking about they're like all right
we'll use discover and then the funny
thing is like discover is going to
become the ultimate champion of 2a
because they're like we found a
community that will use our card and
make it prominent popular and then think
about the peripheral area you got people
who are like i don't use visa and
mastercard anymore because they're
they're they're tracking us it's creepy
then the pizza shop next door is gonna
be like okay we'll we'll bring and
discover and then all of a sudden boom
discover wins but what was interesting
about this whole thing is that like for
them
they see this as like a a act of virtue
you know right like
they they genuinely believe that by
um
you know
kind of monitoring uh to what extent
people are buying guns with their
credit cards they are
um
keeping down gun violence you know i
mean so it's like it's ridiculous it's
crazy yeah mastercard i remember uh just
even a year ago i was trying to use it
at a local gun shop in new hampshire and
they're like oh you have to run it twice
because uh mastercard has a new policy
that they don't want people using their
card in gun stores but if you run it
twice it's fine yeah so but you run it
once they'll automatically decline it
and then you have to run it in a special
way and they'll allow it i never had
that problem you should bring cash back
know that so this is this should be a
message to like us as consumers is like
you know go with a company a credit card
company or whomever who will keep your
information private like you know i'm
talking to you discover come on yeah i
hope somebody at discover is right now
calling his boss being like this is our
chance yeah we're taking over yeah all
right william hines says you mention
ezekiel being too graphic then the bible
should be removed censored from schools
you pick one verse out of 31 000. the
whole point of genderqueer is grooming
young adult minds the bible is not the
same
i'm not saying the entirety of the bible
should be uh well the bible's
substantially longer
than genderqueer my point is
if there is a book that contains graphic
imagery is that is that the case if your
argument william is that one book is
intended to groom and one isn't well
then you've made your argument i didn't
say that was right or wrong i simply
asked a question of our guest
so the point was if genderqueer includes
graphic depictions in the book you guys
have seen it right that book where it's
like you know yeah yeah i don't want to
say it and then i'm like the bible also
includes graphic depictions in ezekiel
notably 23 20 and then i was like is
that comparable so it's a question just
say no but the point isn't like you know
the graphic imagery the point is like
what
what ideology or what world view is
you know whatever
content like what it what is it pedaling
or was it what is it
presenting
at it you know as its core its purpose
you know i mean what is his purpose and
so it's like yeah like the world is a
very volatile place you know i mean so
it's like whether it's coming from a
awoke liberal or whether it's coming
from a a fundamental christian
like what is the the the basic point of
what it is that's being presented and so
for for me i i genuinely believe that
the christian
worldview the christian ethic
um presents a
a worldview that is is
um that can basically produce
uh the the best possible
um
the best possible
uh world view that's that's
that can contribute to human flourishing
whereas a woke worldview doesn't so yeah
is that if that makes sense so ladies
and gentlemen if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and become a member at
timcast.com because we're going to have
a members only after show uncensored not
family friendly this one's going to piss
you off it's about schools and a teacher
and i teach you got fired for doing a
thing to a child but it's not what you
think and uh maybe it is i don't know
but we're going to talk about how
they've been hurting kids how the covet
policies hurt kids so that'll be up at
timcats.com at 11. so for those of you
that have spotify
look up timcast artist page and add will
of the people and only ever wanted to
your playlists and play them all the
time if you enjoy the music because
we're gonna be rolling out new music
every few weeks the plan for now is uh
we've got an album of mine to finish
then um carter has music he's the
producer and engineer that he's going to
release ian has some music he's going to
release then we're going to be signing
more bands and we're going to creating
some other new projects and bands and
producing a ton of music so you can
support us by adding will of the people
and only ever wanted to your playlists
and just listening to them as often as
you'd like to enjoy them and a bunch of
other stuff coming too don't forget to
check out tom mcdonald's riot we're
shouting him out we want to help him get
to number one so he's awesome if you're
not familiar with his work you really
got to check it out his political
messages and lyrics are really really
great so you can follow the show at tim
castro you can follow me at timcast do
you guys want to shout anything out
uncle tom2 or any of your socials yeah
just uncle tom.com you can uh buy both
films there all of our social media is
there and
you know please support the film if you
enjoy the film uh please go to imdb
and write us a review and share it with
your uh
friends and family right now yeah i mean
i would just say that like you know
don't be discouraged or don't don't
think that okay so you guys came out
with a sequel a sequel so you know i've
been there done that like this movie is
in essence a film that stands on its own
it is a sequel but it is literally a
film that stands on its own so it's like
this is a film that is in many ways
superior to the first one in the sense
that like we go deeper we take the
audience deeper and we trust the
intelligence for
the intelligence of our audience to
think in a deeper way to see not only
what went on in the past but what's
going on right now as we speak and so
um
for
what what tends to happen in the
conservative movement is we tend to
recoil or recant
uh the moment that the word racist is
hurled at us
and so what this film does is it puts
history in its proper perspective
so as to equip you with the knowledge
that you need so as to not be constantly
intimidated by
a leftist narrative that is in the sense
of revisionist history and so
uh and this like like justin said go to
uncle tom.com this movie will give you
the knowledge you need and encourage you
to do the research that's necessary to
not
be a coward in a public square as far as
our history is concerned thank you guys
so much for coming it was great it's
good to be back and uh shouts out to the
person in the comments that called me
ghost boy that was a good one
i appreciated that one i have a youtube
channel youtube.com forward slash we are
change and again i poured into
a lot into yesterday's video a lot about
my personal experiences being in new
york city on 911 i really put a lot of
blood sweat and tears into it and
youtube just just totally just like
didn't show it to anyone fight the
algorithm check it out on youtube.com
forward slash we are change it would
mean a lot to me thank you so much for
having me thank you guys all very much
for tuning in for this wonderful evening
with the guys from uncle tom2 just you
guys will check that out on their
website you guys can follow me on
twitterminds.com at sourpatchlids as
well as sarahpatriots.me we'll see you
all over at timcast.com thanks for
hanging out bye guys
you